where now today moving more specifically
to the impact of new technologies uh
we've got two sessions both of those
sessions are very important day I know
one of them has attracted more attention
than the other but both of our sessions
today are very important I'm delighted
that we've got the witnesses that we
have here
um the first session is about the
opportunities and challenges around AI
for performers writers and visual
artists including intellectual property
the use of image and audio likenesses
and the automation of work and then when
we get to the second session that we'll
be looking at a particular project Ada
the robot as a case study for some of
the issues which I hope will be able to
explore uh first with our Witnesses so
please may I ask you to introduce
yourselves and tell us the name of the
organization that you represent and I'll
start with Dr gadamus yes I'm
I'm a reader in the intellectual
property law of the University of Sussex
I'm also the chief editor of the Journal
of world Intel property and I've been
studying this for about 10 years thank
you
I'm Paul Fleming I'm the General
Secretary of equity the Trade union for
performers directors designers dancers
choreographers children's entertainers
burlesque artists comedians children's
and so on and so on very good Mr Conway
hello I'm duncanway I'm chief executive
officer at the Publishers association
with the trade body for publishing in
the UK across consumer publishing
education and academic journals okay
thank you I should have said at the
start that we are currently transmitting
live on the internet a recording will be
taken both a written transcript and
video and both of which will be
published on our website of course uh
first question law Bishop thank you uh
well can I have my own thanks to you for
being with us this afternoon and I have
to say that I'm really delighted to be
able to question real life human beings
and not be
um confronted with a robot to begin with
um
we've we hear an awful lot about the
potential of of AI and I I was really
delighted uh to read that Ernesto report
suggests that the UK is currently one of
the world's leading research centers in
AI has a strong position in AI Resort
searching domains potentially relevant
for the creative industry such as our
working on image text and sound data
there's also of course a lot of hype
around Ai and the first question is is a
rather General one in which I'd be
grateful if each of you could say
something about what you see as the
possibilities the potential and indeed
the pitfalls
um for AI in changing the way uh
creative and cultural content is
produced in the next five to ten years
so should I start this end Mr Conway
thank you and it's it's a real Delight
to be here so thank you for having me
um the Publishers Association we've been
thinking about the opportunities of AI
for a few years now and about two years
ago we produced a report called people
plus machines which looked at the
opportunities for AI across the
publishing value chain so all the way
through from content generation and
acquisition through to product
development and then and then sales and
marketing
and the reason that we did that is
because of a general uh perception of
the debate in this area which is that
often
um we feel it's it's seen that there's
AI Innovation going on over here and
then we've got the creative Industries
over here and that they actually stand
in opposition to one another and the
same would go for AI and IP that that
one stymies the other and the reason
that we wanted to produce the report was
to show that in a sector like publishing
there already is a huge amount of AI
Innovation ongoing and actually our
overarching view is that AI in the
creative Industries enhances human
creativity and and doesn't doesn't
replace it so we've seen a huge amount
of AI activation across across
publishing as I say throughout the whole
the whole value chain and usually that's
about
um actually saving the human Creator
from the jobs they don't really want to
do so
um take take an academic researcher for
example who's trying to make sense of
the world's academic content on a
particular issue it's incredibly helpful
for that academic actually to be able to
use a piece a piece of AI to go out and
collect all the information to allow
that that sort of content creativity
generation to take place and then
further down the supply chain in in
publishing we have Publishers using AI
to tackle plagiarism copyright
infringement
in education there are some really
interesting things going on with
adaptive education Technologies so
Learners can engage with education
platforms and that platform can teach
that specific Learner in real time
dependent on you know where they are in
their in their learning cycle and then
much like other other sectors we use AI
in our sales and marketing divisions as
well so
um it's probably not as headline
catching as as the witness that will
follow us but um you know things like
stock management and demand forecasting
and just real life business things so
our overarching position is that AI
already is employed all the way through
the publishing sector and is
overarchingly a Force for goods in the
sense that it helps creative businesses
becomes more become more efficient and
reinforces the human Creator rather than
replacing it thank you thank you
um
so I suppose well
it's perhaps first important to caveat
any talk about AI in a sort of
historical perspective the first ever
Equity General Secretary to give
evidence to a parliamentary select
committee was in 1931 and in 1931 item
five in our annual report was talking
about the threats and opportunities of
recording
um theater Productions and the rise of
Hollywood so I mean there is a degree
there is a little bit of history
repeating itself with some of the
hyperbole around
um Ai and I suppose that we would see it
dividing very straightforwardly as a
trade Union into two areas so there are
the areas of of a growing area of work
for members
um computer games and the ability for
your voice to be used the synthesization
of
um your body your movements and so on
and actually indeed some of the
labor-saving things from jobs which are
members didn't particularly enjoy doing
and you probably don't realize but an
awful lot of commercial radio Jingles
that you hear now are in Timeless
emphasized and created from a melody of
different voices that's where it's not
particularly creatively fulfilled for
members it's not what they're
particularly relish doing it is
nevertheless work that they do do and
actually that has taken some of the the
brunt out of that so there is an awful
lot of extra work that is created
through AI in both broadened and quite a
narrow sense the real risks of AI from
our members point of view are on the
labor market and I'll try and make it
really really clear that our members are
no more effective than somebody who
encounters AI because they work on the
checkouts at a supermarket somebody
works on checkouts at a supermarket is
not seen their hours decrease their pay
increase it stays stable or indeed
increase because the profits that have
potentially garnered are larger and
actually what they've seen is their
hours decrease their their relative pay
decrease and their work become more
precarious because of the introduction
of AI into their working lives so if you
take the instance of radio Jingles Well
Radio Jingles actually tended to pay
broadly quite well it's quite repetitive
work so you have to pay quite a lot to
incentivize an artist to do it it's
those relatively higher levels of wages
that facilitate our members working in
poorer paid area Performing Arts most
notably theater and live performance if
you think about people who will walk on
or supporting artists who have now
essentially been largely erased from big
budget films who are now replicated for
battle scenes or crowd scenes and
completely and utterly cooked up in the
background are our members pay is it
increasing from other engages and is the
pay an ongoing usage payments
um for that work is it fair
proportionate or in a way that's going
to sustain a creative Workforce no it is
not
and that's doubled up with the problem
that where we've dealt with AI in very
established areas of work 95 of British
TV and film is made on a union
Collective Agreement we've managed you
know Star Wars or all that sort of stuff
quite well within that framework but if
you think about new and emerging areas
we have one agreement for video games
and you know those sorts of areas of new
work are more difficult to unionize and
then finally it is that we'll talk more
about it later I suspect but the overall
intellectual property framework
um the right time members have the moral
rights that they can depend on
um that framework in this country is
weak it's not helpful for our collective
bargaining position and it's not helpful
in terms of protecting our members from
unreasonable exploitation so there are
opportunities of new work but there are
serious risks within the impact of those
opportunities and our ability to respond
to them thank you that's really helpful
yes I would like first to address uh
perhaps the the question of the hype and
there is definitely quite a lot of hype
on artificial intelligence
some of it is Justified some of it is
unjustified and I would say that just
looking at the area
as I've been doing for for many years
something that has struck me is there
has been a very clear advance in the
particularly in in the last couple of
years on the technology itself and
things that were not possible seven
years ago I when I look at the things
that I was using even seven years ago
the capacity of the artificial
intelligence is at a different level
entirely a different level some things
even in the last six months that we're
seeing uh things are changing and
particularly in the creative Industries
things like art
um I don't know if if any anyone here
has played with some of the tools Dali a
stable diffusion mid Journey it's like
magic you type a few words and you
create something that that it appears to
be like magic so there is some
justification on the hype
um
having said that
um there are also I think possibilities
and challenges that these Revolution is
bringing it's a revolution and I cannot
stay stay this enough it's a revolution
akin to the personal computer and the
mobile phone the smartphone I think it's
something once you start seeing it what
you start using it is amazing however
um there are challenges and challenges
that have been mentioned already I think
that there's quite the potential to have
artists and creators be affected by this
there are people that are very angry
very vocal that their livelihoods are
going to be affected by by the
technology and that I think that's
something that we have to explore as
well
thank you thank you can I just um to
come back um you you both that's the uh
outlined uh potential and pitfalls but
but Mr Conway you you were pretty much
exclusively positive do you see negative
sides in in your area or not
well I think there's some real
difficulties about the way that the IP
framework is working but I know I know I
know we're going to come on to that
um in terms of sort of Labor Market
substitution
um in you know in in consumer book
traditional publishing it's just not
something that that we're seeing
um uh but but I can see that in other
areas the creative Industries perhaps
that is perhaps that is a a concern I
think my view on that would be that
particularly in fiction publishing
you know the creative process is and and
and the audiences the reader's reception
of that creative process is quite
complicated so you know I heard um as
I'm sure all of the members of the
committee did I heard um Ada on The
Today program this morning talk and and
you know the conversation was around you
know is creativity just a process
and I think in our view the publishing
view is no it isn't and the reason for
that is that it's the it's it's also
about how that process is is received
you know part of the creative the beauty
of the creative Industries it's got the
kind of emotional connection between a
human author in my sector and a and a
human reader
and you know I've I've seen that you
know Ada who's incredibly impressive and
I'm looking forward to staying and
listening to her
um uh is able to produce Oscar Wilde's
poetry through being able to through
being fed Oscar Wilde's poetry and
that's incredibly impressive but it's
not Oscar Wilde's poetry and I don't
think that if you know Oscar Wilde's a
happy prince was written by a machine it
would be the tear jerker that it is
so you know while I concede that there
may be some labor market
um amendments in relation to AI probably
in my sector in relation to
um potentially more specialist Works
um with a smaller readership perhaps
away from fiction we're just not seeing
the sort of same level that with respect
Paul Paul may be fearing in his sector
just a supplementary from Bonus bull
it's a really short question on tear
jerkers because I think you're
using but I think we were hearing that
some jingles and jingle like music and
perhaps some you know schmaltzy themes
are being written by Ai and may well be
tear jerkers if they learn about the you
know the little catch moment when can
you think of a tear joke I'm looking I'm
looking at you can you think of a tear
joke a piece of music that's been
written by a machine it does this
argument go across all art forms or is
there something specific about the
written word
I mean I I've never been brought to
Tears by uh um you know windscreen
replacement advert so I'm not sure that
uh prices perhaps but the adverts know I
I I I think but I I I think there is
there is a danger so if we talk about I
I've
um there's the the idea that AI would
for instance read a novel in the place
of one of the audio readers of our
members and produce the same emotional
reaction in an audience
um at the and it certainly seems untrue
but I think we're perhaps naive to think
that it would not become untrue and
because ultimately what is ai ai is
reliant on our own intelligence and
anything we can do a machine can do and
as long as it you know it advances far
enough so um I think it's certainly true
it's not an immediate challenge to
re-pre to reproduce that in a very very
intense artistic process but does the
effect of a battle scene you know or or
indeed the the effect of video game that
you've controlled which are all real
human movements but actually are
responding very different ways can they
produce you know similarly heightened
emotion I think they probably can
it was just to say that I mean
could theoretically a robot uh generate
a book
um based on whatever you inferred to it
and could that not ultimately replace
Publishers having to pay authors
the answer is yes
um it's already happening it's possible
it's not going to be at your Joker it's
not going to be the the height of
literature but it's already possible
it's the technology is already capable
of producing possible Works let's say
it's it's producing art that looks very
nice I've made a few myself that people
have liked
um I it's possible to produce music
again it's not going to be the most
amazing that's cheaper than human being
exactly then what's going to happen yeah
it's going that's potentially the
competition aspect is going to produce
lots and lots of works that are low
quality not the most amazing yes that's
the point
just before we move on to to the next
question I just wondered if I could uh
ask Mr Fleming in the in the context of
of performance as it were I mean I I
understand the concerns that you've
expressed and will come back later on to
um impact on the on the labor market I
just wondered if there was anything
positive that you wanted to say about AI
in things like choreography or you know
the kind of the the
anything that makes the the sort of
production as it were of a of a
you know a show or whatever sort of
different or improve it in some way that
um you know wasn't there before I'm just
I'm just trying to see if there's
another angle in terms of the positive
side of this that we haven't heard
I mean I'm a trade Union bureaucrat so
not particularly well qualified to
comment on autistic matters
um members who are yeah I I I think I I
think what what we would say is that it
does open up a new playing of art it
does open up a new a mode of expression
it does open up new opportunities for
our members to work and whether it be
through a completely new format like a
video game
um type scenario or indeed films that
are completely constructed
um or or or indeed you know we will be
very familiar with the star vehicle the
the in in a production so you have a a
theater show or a TV show or a film
that's made around an individual the
possibility to reanimate people or to
put them in different scenarios does
open up a range of different artistic
possibilities and that as I say is is
the art question is perhaps a different
one than for the union but um the in
terms of whether we're not utterly diets
on this there is definitely new spheres
of Art and new spheres of expression new
spheres of work which are opened up by
Ai and that is singularly in University
positive the real question is securing
the best terms and conditions in that
exploitation okay well let's say we'll
come back to that uh in due course well
I think speaking of somebody who has
worked quite a lot with choreographers
um you can see that there's a difference
only using it as an example yeah you
know exactly but but there is there is a
difference between this sort of Baseline
you know the Standard Generation of of
you know okay material and true works of
art and actually great for somebody like
Wayne McGregor have been using
technology in ways that you know
supplement and enhance and create an
experience that wouldn't be possible
otherwise so I I think it's back to that
point you know yes you can churn stuff
out from a machine or you can use the
machine to create some thing that's only
possible with the machine and the human
partnership okay
we're moving on to intellectual property
yes we are sorry I'm moving across to
another screen thank you so um yes I
wanted to my questions about the
challenges that AI presents to the
creative Industries in terms of
intellectual property and I understand
that quite unusually in the UK copyright
law protects works not only generated by
individuals including individuals
partnering with air but it also protects
work which is generated by a computer
where there's no human involved I
understand that's quite unusual and I'm
really interested in that argument
because as I understand it the legal
definition of originality which has to
be met before copyright law click kicks
in is based on human characteristics and
no robot can have those so that's
interesting there are differing views
too I think on whether the laws still
fit for purpose whether the moment is
now to update or whether it's too early
so Keen to hear from each of you and I
think I'll start without with our with
our academic if I may what are your
views on the main challenges for the
creative Industries in terms of
intellectual property yes thank you very
much
um I am perhaps
I like to start by making a distinction
that usually when we're talking about
artificial intelligence and copyright
we're talking about both authorship and
liability so as you mentioned already
there is a question of authorship but
also a very important we're looking at
potentially changing the law with the
liability so let me start with
authorship
um the UK is unique perhaps unique in it
was the first country that passed this
and many a few other countries have
copied this which is section 9 paragraph
three of the cdpa of the copyright
designs and patents act that gives
copyright or says that the author of a
work of a computer-generated work is is
going to be given copyright so whoever
made the arrangements necessary for the
work to coming to being is going to be
the author so this is unique because not
many countries have this and um
some people as you have mentioned argue
that this is in Clash with the
intellectual creation requirement that
is an originality in copyright so we
have this potential dichotomy that we
have and protection for computer
generated works and
um
a requirement of intellectual creation
now at the moment we don't have case law
this hasn't been decided in any case but
also most importantly this uh this
provision was generated before
um artificial intelligence so where
people were thinking initially was more
robotic painters like you're going to
see later so that was the origin of of
the provision and there wasn't a
consultation last year and it concluded
this year by the ukip office and they
asked those questions they asked three
questions mainly should the law be
changed should
this computer-generated provision be
repealed or should we have a new sui
generis right and myself and many other
academics we chose to go for option zero
which was keep the law as it is and
that's what the UK IP office decided
um
apologies I'm going to go a little bit
on
so right now I think that's the solution
we're just going to wait and see what
happens the provision is there it's you
it's Unique only very few countries have
the same provision so now moving to the
liability part could a robot could an
artificial intelligence infringe
copyright and that is potentially a very
very important question and here the UK
is also a leader in in this area
um as far as I know the UK was the first
country to pass an exception for
copyright for text and data mining and
that was back in 2014 with there are a
bunch of exceptions that were passed at
the Time parody Pastiche and other
exceptions and one of them was for Texan
data mining for research purposes
um that is the law as it is and with the
consultation there was uh taking place
as well
um the same consultation that I
mentioned and the same question was
asked whether or not we should keep that
as it is written or we should expand it
now
and I'm sorry I'm I'm going on quite a
lot but it's it's a very complicated
area and Europe has actually the
European Union has passed uh a directive
in 2019 called the digital signal Market
directive and this directive
um
contains
two exceptions to take some data mining
the training of our artificial
intelligence in article 3 which is
pretty much the same that we have in the
UK and in article 4 it has an exception
for
text and data mining but for commercial
purposes so the UK exception is for
research only and their exception is now
for commercial users but as long as the
author the owner doesn't reserve the
right so it's an opt-out system
um
the
the UK consultation the UK IPO
consultation came up with the solution
that the UK should Implement something
that goes beyond that so an exception to
copyright uh that is for commercial
purposes for all commercial purposes
without a knockout
and that is this uh the consultation
that was presented in June of 2022.
sorry that was a long very long answer
I'm I'm afraid and you
shall opt out
for creators or Publishers for instance
[Music]
um right now it allows someone let's say
an artist that does not want their art
to be included in a data set that is
going to be used to train uh to be in a
machine learning program so right now in
Europe with that opt out an artist can
go and say I don't want my art to be in
in this data set the implication of that
opt-out is that it allows I think it's a
good compromise
um owners and copyright owners copyright
authors have the possibility of saying I
don't want to participate in this near
future of machines and machine learning
that is the
uh what is going to happen I don't know
I think that nobody knows uh it hasn't
been implemented quite a lot in Europe
it was just in 2019 uh with the pandemic
lots of things having just been
implemented
countries are just starting to implement
this so we really don't know the idea of
the ukip office and the and the
consultation is stated that they want
the UK to become a leader a leader
specifically
to have companies come and establish
artificial intelligence data mining
operations here
yeah thank you that that supplementary
was very very helpful Paul from your the
perspective of your members just before
you go on uh be honest but are you
looking for a point of clarification yes
it was actually could you just explain
to us when you say
um uh that work or whatever in that data
set be very helpful if you do explain
exactly what in that data set means both
uh commercially versus for research
purposes
um
to give you an example a a very large
data set of art that is now being used
for a training some of these tools that
you're seeing like Dali and and all of
these things there is a very popular
data set called lion
l-a-i-o-n and that concerns four
point five billion images that con that
is photographs that is Art etc etc and
the important thing of this is that it
contains images but also description so
that the machine knows when you're
asking for Paddington Bear painted by
Van Gogh he knows what Paddington Bear
looks like and he knows what Van Gogh
paintings look like because there is a
in the data set that is that is
contained in both now from a perspective
of um
um
someone that is putting together all of
this data
potentially that could be infringing
copyright but there is there is a copy
that is in the in the data set so the
data set is is public you can download
it it's uh it's available there are
people that actually have created
browsers where you can look if an image
of yours is there and I look myself I
I'm actually three photographs of myself
are in the in the data set so that is
what it means it's just a collection a
large collection of Works a large
collection of
um of pictures images
etc etc that has metadata with it and
from a corporate perspective it could be
infringe incorporate so that is what we
mean including it's making a copy into a
data set
um
an exception an exception particularly
for research purposes is that that data
set is not infringing copyright putting
all of these images in the data set if
you're doing it for research the end
usage is key exactly the the usage is is
absolutely key thank you
I think Paul came to understand from
Bill members perspective the challenges
that AI presents in terms of
intellectual property
um
so I suppose we'd say that there are
three principal deficiencies in the
legislative framework as it is
um and I'll kind of go with them in
ascending order if you like the first is
around
um image rights and the lack of clarity
around image rights and in this country
this is something that American states
have been dealing with for some time
Californians might expect had
legislation brought in in the mid-1980s
to try and deal with it and now there's
a range of case law to support the
rights of deceased artists to control
over their image their work and so on
that is critical to starting to deal
with this synthesization phenomenon the
Deep fake phenomenon the use of
um very identifiable
um uh images movements speech patterns
of people to promote products they're
not in favor of promote political causes
they're not in favor of create videos
they don't want to be created and so on
and so that I suppose is kind of issue
one where there is a deficiency in in in
the legislative framework from our
members perspective
um the second is around this data mining
issue which has been touched on far more
exploited than I can do but it is pretty
clear what the worry from our members
perspective is if you look at where AI
is really directly impacting terms of
conditions right now which is the
creation of synthesized adverts
commercials movements
um you know why do you need to engage
several artists to put together all the
movements that go into a video game if
you can want in the data mine and the
opting out of it is highly complex
particularly for an individuals one
thing if you are a corporation with
intellectual property that wishes to
remove it or you know big large sort of
photojournalism firms or whatever if
you're an individual performer trying to
pick that out that's quite difficult
and that Gap if you're like in the
legislation rests on what's probably the
biggest problem
um is the protection of audio but not
the protection of audio visual
performances with the same sorts of
copyright as other areas of work
um and that comes from a long-standing
tension you know is it the director's
copyright is it the artist copyright is
the choreographers copyright and so on
and so on and so on so you can
understand where that tension comes from
but fundamentally there is not
protection there is not copyright
protection for a performance performance
if we think about Lawrence Olivier's
Hamlet it's not protected not really and
that is a very very very serious problem
as you start to move into a world where
AI gets better and TV and film gets
better as well now we on we are not in
favor of a of a over regulated system
um with statutory remuneration for our
members and so on we um have very very
strong collectively bargained agreements
across the audio visual sector that
protect our members frankly they are
more flexible and responsive than a
legislative approach they deliver better
returns for members and members receive
significantly better royalties and
secondary payments and their colleagues
in Continental Europe because we
bargained them better and that's allowed
us to be flexible as new technology as
arisen but so this isn't a question
where we're asking for audio visual
performances to be protected to create a
statutory framework of royalties and
which is often the often the ambition
elsewhere in the world what we would
like is an acknowledgment of it in law
that's what the government this country
has signed up to in signing the Beijing
treaty they've said they're going to do
it but I haven't ratified that treaty so
there's this enormous gap for audio
visual performers specifically who of
course are some of the biggest exports
of this country and whose work is some
of the best exports in this country
whose work is essentially unprotected in
the face of growing AI that I think in
terms of Ip and whatever is the biggest
overarching issue
um and allowing us to have the framework
to collectively bargain within to
deliver the answers that that our
members need to protect in the future
that's really helpful it seems as if
there is a potential solution to that
last one
um in terms of the first two is the
sector is it moving so quickly that that
freezing legislation in time right now
would be a bit meaningless because we
don't know how this is going to develop
it is it's absolutely a risk that you
over engineer these things and by the
time you finish Consulting on them
they're they're broadly irrelevant
um I think I'm very we're very lucky and
what we can look at well it's a highly
unionized sector what we are looking for
essentially is the framework within
which we can bargain to ensure that
individual contracts and agreements have
a legal underpinning we know that
somebody's image rights will go on and
on and on what we'd like to do is
negotiate ourselves through our
Collective agreements appropriate
payments going forward and we see that
already in film when they're reanimating
big actors in Star Wars they're on our
Collective agreements on British
Collective agreements we have delivered
the proper outcomes for the estate so
people protect their intellectual
property that's fine because it's within
that framework one starts to get worried
in the world of computer games and
elsewhere where images and so on and
then there is the question simply the
Deep fake issue the Deep fake issue
which is very different to an artistic
and creative issue but it does impact
our members very directly because of the
nature of the work that they do I think
it's very important to separate those
issues out you know from synthesized
performance and deep folks they're very
very different issues but the framework
that's required there is a much stronger
moral intervention frankly from the
state to protect people's rights to not
be degraded but if I have time just to
go down with the same question from your
perspective please thank you thank you I
think I'm just sort of taking one slight
step back
um I think it's it's often said of the
UK legislative framework that we have
for the UK has got we have the global
gold standard for intellectual property
and copyright and that's that's how we
feel I think that's how the rest of the
creative Industries feels about the
legal backdrop and it's you know the
amazing numbers that were quoted in the
previous session that you ran as part of
this inquiry about the creative
Industries being worth over 100 billion
pounds to the economy the reason for
that is because we have an appropriate
legal framework which allows a market
for creativity allows a market for ideas
and allows creative businesses to to to
to grow and thrive
um there are exceptions to copyright in
UK law rightly so to balance the
interests of the user with the interests
of the the rights order involved
our view on the AI text and data mining
issue is that where the government has
arrived at is is a bit of a sledgehammer
to crack a nut it's a really Broad New
exception without any limitations
um which potentially Falls foul of our
International obligations or
International IP obligations in relation
to the burn convention
and and and and and we would like we'd
like the government to look at it again
and in terms of what it means
practically for publishing
um at the moment as as Dr Vladimir was
saying there's a there is a research
exception in UK law so if you're
conducting research you can for free
access all the data sets you want and
produce your research if you're going to
commercialize that research then you
have to pay a licensing fee to do so and
in a market that feels that feels Fair
as long as that licensing agreement
process is working so where we are
lighted on in response to the
consultation that Dr guatemuse was
talking us all through earlier we didn't
say status quo we we said actually
option one which was let's have a look
at the licensing regime make sure that
if an AI product is looking to mine a
load of data for commercial purposes
that that licensing and those licensing
agreements work and obviously there are
a huge number of different companies
that are looking to do that everything
from large U.S tech firms on the west
coast of the US right through to small
and micro businesses
all over the world and at the moment the
legal provision would allow any of those
businesses of any size located anywhere
in the world to access all of my members
data for free for the purposes of text
and data mining there is no
um differentiation between a large US
tech firm in the U.S and a AI micro
startup in the north of England and what
we've been talking to the IPO about is
to try and engineer to try and you know
talk to them about the licensing regime
and work with them on a more bespoke
legal response that avoids a brand new
wide exception and actually focuses on
this being a market that works and we
have put a number on it for our sector
currently
TDM licensing we think is worth 335
million pounds a year to Publishers and
also it's a nascent area of investment
so that's you know without a legal
provision which undermines it commercial
that's something that would grow over
time
thank you thank you thank you
yeah all right Brown is cheaper I'm just
picking up on that um Dan I thought that
was really interesting because arguably
the publishing industry is a growth
industry post pandemic
um you've made a very eloquent case for
looking at the data mining issue in a
more holistic way
and this campaign
um comes hot on the heels of say
International exhaustion and it seems to
me one of our earlier inquiries we were
looking at legislating the legislators
and you know and I think you referenced
it
um that governments always playing catch
up to the speed of transformation of
industry and I'm just wondering from a
sort of General approach point of view
if you had any thoughts on how you could
work more collaboratively so that you
have to so you could avoid you know
launching great campaigns every five
minutes and and and actually look at
some of the excellent use of some of our
Legacy Legacy you know creative
Industries in using new technologies in
a very positive and fair way so
protecting the past but also adjusting
for the future in a slightly more subtle
way
thank you thank you so obviously we you
know
to us we're we're very important you
know we are 6.7 billion pound industry
and hugely culturally important but I'm
also aware that you know in the grand
scheme of things you know government is
a big beast and it is trying to
legislate for a whole a huge number of
sectors I mean that's partially why this
kind of collective moniker of the
creative Industries is so useful because
it allows Industries like like mine and
the others to club together and carry
some real heft
um it has been a shame for us that we've
had we've faced these intellectual
property uh issues over the past few
years International the threat of
international exhaustion has been a big
one which isn't quite settled yet and
this text and data mining issue as well
you know I I I I would love to there to
be a forum for coordination and
coordinated thinking
um around specifically intellectual
property and the creative uh Industries
and I think you know one of the ways and
uh which we'd like to see this moving
forward is actually a forum which
perhaps government could be can convene
which would bring together academics
industry uh and our industry and
Technology firms around the creative
Industries to look at it as a bit of a
test case for how you bring AI forwards
and actually a bit of coordination and
and discussion and planning perhaps
convened by policy makers could only
could only be a good thing
thank you we're going to move on Lord
Foster well well thank you and thank you
all three it's been absolutely
fascinating so far and I was
particularly struck by Dan's comment
that AI enhances human creativity rather
than replacing it and went on to say
that it's a Force for good and I think
we'd all agree that if we're going to
maximize its potential we need to have
the right legal and legislative
framework to minimize the possible
downsides and and challenges and in
relation to those challenges we've
already just discussed the IP ones
others have been touched on around
workers rights such as contracts or
artists engaging in AI work or labor
market substitution and I think we're
already well aware there are a number of
others such as data bias and so on so I
just wonder if each of you could just
talk about what you see as the broader
challenges and how best we go about
addressing them and and if I start with
you Paul not least because you said
um very clearly that you are not in
favor of either over regulation or over
engineering so we have to find ways of
doing it that don't do that either so do
you want to kick off
and I suppose I'll go back to to our
um that
the core of where we are I mean the
creative Industries as as Dan said
um are worth more to British economy
than banking but actually it is
incredibly low paid sector we have 47
000 members and we're talking about 10
of them
um earning at those sort of very very
top high brackets that people associate
with
um you know celebrities or performers we
we we reckon around about 80 to 90 of
our members are earning less than 20 000
pounds a year from the industry itself
that is incredibly low pay
and fundamentally what you have is a a
is is a a a bit of a growing problem
that those areas of of work which
sustain them through periods of low pay
are about to be removed entirely from
the market because of the speed of AI
intervention now that is not necessarily
a bad thing as I say because it's
opening up other opportunities for
employment but the but what needs to be
created from our members point of view
and an absolutely for audio visual
performance it does a very very
different position from from from other
artists is to create a legislative
starting point for us to ensure that we
can go directly to emerging producers
emerging creators of work such as video
games producers and so on and say look
you here have a a statutory obligation
on you to provide some form of
remuneration going forward to
acknowledge the moral rights that our
members have in their performance
therefore come together and negotiate it
with us because the threat of
legislation the threat of that straight
jacket as happens in
European instead of a collectively
bargained solution to this which is what
works the vast majority of the creative
in the vast majority of the areas in
which our members work
um it isn't going to happen without that
as a bit of a kick
um to those producers those creators of
content who are not used to operating in
a unionized environment and I think that
that is in terms of the broad challenge
you risk removing from the workforce
large swathes of people so after the
pandemic 90 of our black women members
are talking about exiting the industry
90 of them and this is a group who are
in growing cultural demand for their
inputs into products but they are
talking about leaving the industry if we
talk about our deaf and disabled members
those figures are almost as high we're
talking about 56 of those people haven't
considered leaving the industry those
are people for whom AI should be
facilitating more access to work it
should be making work easier for them to
access and the the the the the the the
the the the the risk of course is that
um as pay stays low new opportunities
for pay are not supported with the
legislative framework actually those
people who struggle to find work
struggle to be represented within the
industry in times of good end up being
forced out when times are hard so of
course the Trade union official is going
to say what's the biggest issue it's
people's terms and conditions moving
forward and their ability to bargain
them and that that I think is you make
that very clear and it's very helpful
but other wider issues wider concerns
that you have as well that we haven't
perhaps touched on yet that you think we
should be thinking about
I mean I I I I I I I I don't because I
don't think it's too complicated an
issue even though it sometimes seems
um somewhat overwhelming there's
intellectual property issues there are
issues about people's rights when
they're at work in the in the first
instance there are the creative issues
um as to what what and that kind of
intersection between intellectual
property that needs to be considered I
think it's quite easy to distill this
into some very straightforward questions
that legislators need to answer instead
of getting slightly distracted by how
overwhelming the whole thing is all we
need is a simple straightforward
framework and I think the questions are
being asked are the right ones they're
very helpful if you drop those questions
down and send them to us to have a look
at uh Dr grademos yes perhaps
besides all the things that we've been
discussing about intelligible property
and leaving my field a little bit
because I've been watching what has been
happening
it's interesting to me how fast things
move I don't know if you remember when a
translation artificial intelligence
translation started people would laugh
at it it was a little bit you try to
translate something
um and it it translated things very
badly until it didn't and it completely
changed and now it produces text that is
absolutely readable not only readable
but I can I can use in many
circumstances that means that this is
replacing translators it's already a
profession that is almost dying out
because artificial intelligence has an
effect and there are things that we
don't even know that are potentially
changing right now so there are all
other Industries I was just reading
today that students are using artificial
intelligence to make to write their
homeworks and not only that one student
got an artificial intelligence to write
an essay justifying the use of
artificial intelligence in their to to
write their homework and it was very
good it was quite possible so this is
the thing that we're starting to to we
have to Grapple with and I think that
the Societies in general we don't we
haven't realized that the changes are
happening already happened are happening
and will happen and
I don't know what the industries are
going to do to look like the creative
Industries are going to look like
Academia what happens with uh students
can write essays with just putting a few
instructions with artists already
happening with music is potentially
happening video all sorts of things and
I don't know what's going to happen but
we need to as a society have a challenge
for thinking about these things
um we're going to have almost unlimited
content that is going to compete with
human content it's not going to be very
good but it's going to be free
potentially so yeah I don't know I don't
know what the answer is so in summary
the challenge is that we don't know what
the challenges are going to be yes but
we've also got to think about how we
prepare ourselves for that yeah
there are known unknowns as they said
they're engaged yeah
so um without wanting to repeat what I
perhaps what I said earlier you know I
don't think in the publishing sector
we're expecting the kind of Labor Market
difficulties Perhaps Perhaps Paul is um
uh soliloquently talking about in in his
own sector I do think I was interested
in what you were saying Dr Vladimir is
there about there being unlimited
content competing with human content but
it being possible and not all not very
good
um to go back to what I said at the
beginning you know I think actually that
isn't that the point here that we are
dealing with an information boom
from Human creators but also from AI
creators and actually to go back to the
report that we produced some of these
Technologies are going to be really
really helpful in making sense of a lot
of that and supporting human creativity
so just to return to what I said before
you know our perspective is that um is
that AI can be can be a force for good
for human creativity within that
framework but the the one thing that
that none of you have touched on is is
real concerns around data bias the way
in which we use AI uses the information
we provide to then create new stuff so
we end up getting more and more of
exactly the same stuff and in that sense
you could argue there we're going to
miss out that creativity issue and we
are interested in the creative
Industries so how do we address that
challenge
so it must be true about books just as
it is about plays it is about television
theater whatever
I think it's a really really important
point it's it's
um we don't just want an AI boom right
we want an AI
AI outputs that are accurate and that
work and that are usable and I think
just to go back to the TDM issue the
real problem with that for us as a
sector is if effectively you
disintermediate the people who are
responsible for making that data
accurate
and you ruin the investment case for
building data sets that are correct and
balanced
uh effectively what you're doing is
undermining the investment case in the
underlying data so what you might be
able to do is expand access
um uh to all types of AI software
commercial AI software that wants to use
it but you're undermining the
fundamental investment case and the data
that underpins that and so the outputs
that you get is your as your as you're
rightly pointing out the outputs that
you get will not be will not be the
right ones and that's why we need the
right legal framework to to underpin
this
do you want to comment on that book
I suppose I mean to to some extent I
mean capitalism itself tends to
overproduction doesn't it so as a con
it's the the the consequence of an AI
boom is is in terms of its impact on
creativity is probably
the same as it would be anyway and I
think again as legislators look at this
they have to look at it in in a broader
context of are we having the right State
intervention is the creative Industries
are we adequately funding our theaters
are we advocating funding our PVC
channel is the the structure right for
channel four are we actually having the
structural interventions into these
industries where actually what what what
what is AI doing it's responding to
markets it is behaving like
um it is producing content for markets
and consumers that already exist
the real question for the creative
Industries is do we have a sufficient
framework to be adequately subsidizing
human content to in order to intervene
in that market I think you're quite
right though because I think one of the
bigger worries from our point of view
um is the impact that it has on on the
kind of uh on the structural bias I
talked about the opportunities that AI
should be bringing for deaf and disabled
members of ours but the impact on
particularly black creators and so on of
what AI reinforces in already structural
um problems with accessing the market
the source of content that's produced
what we believe markets are saying what
we believe people want to consume in
terms of content I I think that that is
probably a bigger short-term issue
because the impact is actually to limit
opportunities for the workforce in the
short term so I think the overproduction
issue can be dealt with by adequate
State intervention in the Arts and
creative Industries to make sure they
are stimulating the right sorts of
content the workforce issue that comes
around I think you're absolutely right
to ask because there is a very we our
membership at the minute is so
precarious
the AI intervention that makes the work
makes the workflow makes the workplace
harder to access for underrepresented
groups is going to be a bigger problem
um this is not my area study there are
people that specialized from bias and
particularly ethical aspects of AI so
um I cannot really comment on on that on
that it's a it's a very interesting
array of study people are working on
this so there are Specialists that are
working on the ethics of AI I can only
say that the biases are there and just
yesterday I was looking at a picture
someone created an image asking using
Dali asking
make a
painting by Diego Rivera of Rich
Mexicans and paint an image by the
regular of poor Mexicans and the poor
Mexicans where the Skins were
considerably darker than the rich
Mexicans so that bias is embedded it in
all of this technology how to tackle
that I'll leave that to Scholars and
colleagues that are working in that area
but the bias is there thank you all very
much
thank you moving on again baroness
Harding
um thank you all so much this is really
fascinating and I'd like to take you
back um Mr Fleming it was really
interesting you started with the 30s I
want to take you all the way back to
1436 and the invention of the printing
press because I think what we've been
talking about today is the challenges of
new technology you know and and history
shows us that from the printing press
and actually probably go even further
back than that that you can't actually
stop the new technology coming but what
you can do is either choose to embrace
it or not
and you can also choose whether to
mitigate the harms or not and we spent
most of this session so far talking
about how to mitigate the harms I'd like
to take you to what should we be doing
to embrace the opportunity because if
you look at the history of the printing
press actually the single biggest issue
for countries in the 15th century was
the ones that chose to embrace it drove
literacy and growth for the next 300
years the ones that chose not to embrace
it didn't regardless of how much
mitigation there was to the harms of the
printing press that it brought so can I
take you all to what are the
opportunities that AI could bring the UK
and how would you assess how well we're
doing and embracing them would you like
to start Mr plan
um
I suppose I I wouldn't want to talk
about the French Press but I'd probably
like to talk about the cries of the
luddites who have got a rather a bad rap
as far as I'm concerned and because they
were concerned about the deceitful use
of new technology I think was their
position and actually what what was
happening to the luddites as they were
seeing
um Machinery come in to undermine
standardized terms and conditions and
undermine pay
um and I I think that the real question
um of whether AI is a success for this
country is do does the creative
Workforce become more diverse and does
it get to share more equitably in the
fruits that it creates
if we are in a situation where what we
have is a shrinking creative Workforce
or certainly a less diverse creative
Workforce and if we have a creative
Workforce which remains as precarious or
become sort of more precarious than it
is now than the AI in intervention has
failed because actually when we talk
about the printing press we talk about
increasing literacy we treat it to talk
about increasing social benefits and and
the the consequent economic benefits of
that if there is not a direct benefit to
the workforce that's creating this stuff
then I think we need to a really serious
look at it and that is not the
experience at the minute the experience
the minute is that there is an awful lot
of fear and it isn't just reaction right
because what we do have and I think you
know I I don't want to is this isn't a
job by job question as to how much you
paid per hour this is a question about
do we become or do we continue to be a
world leading Center for dubbing a
world-leading center for video game
creation which we are
um and and that is absolutely driven by
AI but driven also by the cultural
environment that we have in this country
um can that be sustained can that be
wrong and does that result in the
overall share of the workforce in the
layer in the fruits of the labor they
create that I think is is very much the
test the opportunities are absolutely
you've made your product extremely
eloquently about the impact on on your
members but what else should we be doing
if anything to actually bring the
opportunities that AI presents is that
just going to happen automatically no
government intervention needed no r d
spend or incentives nothing you're
really happy that we will be up there it
with the best in the world on AI if we
do nothing else
how would you assess governments
role and and the UK commercial sector's
role in bringing the opportunities
I I would worry that if if we do not
have a fit for purpose moral framework
for audio visual performances in this
country which they are developing
relatively successful in the United
States they certainly have a bedrock in
Europe you will see production move
elsewhere and that's not being driven by
buses or producers that will be driven
by core Talent who will say I do not
want my image put at risk within this
week framework so actually I think that
is a very very straightforward you know
ratifying the Beijing treaty creating
that moral right impetus for audio
visual performances and then
facilitating the industry to bargain
itself I mean our Union and others
bargaining with with producers I think
is absolutely a way forward it doesn't
require legislative intervention in the
same way so that I think is a is a is a
very very real worry if you have this
huge data mining operation that
potentially undermines areas of work for
our members it's also going to undermine
as Dan has said the the ability of of
others to create those are the areas to
be really really worried and it's not so
much over engineering that is going to
be the problem in the current trajectory
it's going to be a lack of protection
but there is a balance to be strong
so thank you so
um we're really positive about Ai and I
think I think you're entirely right AI
has arrived and there's no point in
trying to turn back the tide and
um I think publishing is an example of
one of the creative Industries which has
embraced AI technology across all of its
value chain and particularly in the
world of academic publishing where
actually we're talking about really big
data companies that are employing AI as
to use recommendation engines to support
research all around the world and
there's some really really developed
thinking in that area and I think we are
an example of a you know a rights holder
industry which kind of hopefully
challenges that assumption that there's
this AI Innovation and technological
innovation happening over here and
there's the creative Industries over
here and never the Tushar meets that's
just not the case our members are
investing in it collaborating with tech
companies and there's some really
interesting things happening
to your question about what should what
should government do and what should
what we think should happen I think it's
it's three things firstly we'd like
legal certainty on the text and data
mining issue we've covered that
extensively but we we do respectfully
feel that the government's arrived at
the wrong
um the wrong conclusion there and that
we that there should be a rethink about
how we
um how we articulate uh the legal
framework around text and data mining so
legal certainty around text and data
mining there's the skills issue which
was covered in your previous session
um more extensively but when I talk to
my publisher members and we talk about
where it's hard to recruit skills data
scientists and AI skills is a real area
of weakness and I know that the office
for AI is looking at working with higher
education and further education colleges
to make sure that the UK education
system is designed in a way which
actually feeds builds up the skills we
need in this area but obviously there's
a time lag to that so you know we would
be very very supportive of um and
enhanced skills package to bring forward
skills in in AI AI we're certainly
seeing that as an area which is which is
difficult to recruit into and the third
one would be just increased partnership
and collaboration between Academia
um the creative Industries Tech and
government I think it's a really
interesting inquiry the committee is
running in relation to the creative
Industries and AI there could be an
ongoing Forum which looked at how this
how this worked in a more holistic way
rather than having the piecemeal
conversations that we feel we're having
at the moment very helpful thank you
um even without any changes in the law
as things stand I think that the UK is a
is already a leader in artificial
intelligence there are companies that
are being created already in the in the
UK there is a very one of the big
players in particularly in art
artificial intelligence is stability Ai
and it's based in the UK and
um with not having changed nothing in
the law I think it's based here and it's
already a one billion dollar valuation
startup so it's already the UK is
already a leader
um I think that in order to attract
potentially more companies and and
become more of a leader
um
the text on data mining exception should
be changed at least to meet the standard
of the European Union at least I think
because otherwise some companies may
actually just go go to France Amsterdam
whatever because they have a better
exception on Pixel data mining so at
least that should be met
um and that's probably what the
government can be doing and the other
thing is I think that the UK IP office
has been doing a fantastic job with the
consultations with the leadership that
is showing in doing research in this
area and it long it may continue I think
that the government has to continue
doing the research and I I also agree
that we need more research on the
effects of this and the creative
Industries
okay thank you I'm gonna have to uh draw
it to to a close right now
um can I say thank you very much to all
three of our Witnesses this has been a
really really helpful session and I'm
very grateful for your openness and
willing to be clear in answering our
questions I'll just say to Mr Fleming if
you are able to
um follow up with the questions that I
referred to in response to the requests
from Lord Foster that would be brilliant
and uh to Mr Conway in terms of skills
just to reassure you that is an area
that we will be coming to look at in
Greater detail and the second part of
this inquiry
um but thank you for now and I'll draw
this to a close order order
okay
um this is the second session of today's
meeting of the creative uh sorry the
communications and digital select
committee and our inquiry into the
future of the creative Industries as I
said earlier we're looking at the risks
and opportunities facing the UK's
creative Industries and particularly the
impact of new technologies
um this is a serious inquiry by this
select committee and we're certainly
examining all of the uh issues and
questions objectively as you would
expect us to can I first of all welcome
Mr Miller and uh and also thank him for
bringing Ada uh the robot and all the
effort that's been involved in making
this happen and we are truly grateful
and could I start Mr Miller by asking
you to briefly introduce yourself and uh
and no doubt introduce Ada as well hello
I'm Aiden Miller I'm the director behind
the Ada Road robot project uh Ada robot
being the first Auto realistic robot
artist
thank you very much indeed okay
um well shall we start then
um do you want to um tell us a little
bit about uh what Ida does and um and
what was their reasoning behind creating
this robot
so Ada is a complex AI robot
she has been designed to mimic a human
and to explore the whole world of AI and
Robotics
it came about as a project because I
could see as someone in the art world
the greatest artists of our time engaged
and questioned the societal shifts that
took place within their times
the more I read about the future and
where we were going as a world I
realized that this very very much needed
discussion debate
um about the nature of Technology wasn't
really having a a lot of air time and in
actual fact I increasingly became very
worried about it
and it was wild my son was playing Lego
he made a little robot out of Lego and
it just was a real moment in actual fact
where I thought
is it actually possible that we could
critique and comment and look at this
whole world of technology by actually
the technology speaking for itself
and as the journey has gone on which has
been quite a quite a journey to this
point I can say it's had many twists and
turns to the whole project
um I've actually realized even more just
how much of a
area that this does need looking at I am
increasingly concerned especially on the
ethical grounds of some of the aspects
of technology so I want to be very clear
that we're not here to promote robots
any aspects of specific technology it
really is a contemporary art project
that is looking at the nature of
technology today okay well thank you for
that
um could I could you explain why you
decided I mean you've kind of touched on
it but but why you decided to make the
robot at a sort of represent a human
type uh figure and what made you choose
to gender it and adopt a female gen and
yes extremely confusing threatening
worrying I've had all sorts of Articles
written about this it's actually because
of the group of people behind Ada so
there's over 30 people that put Ada
together many
male and female and there was two
aspects to it one is that the females
within the group were very clear that
they wanted a high female representation
in the tech and art worlds which are
largely male but actually as time has
gone on enormous discussion has gone in
this area and we're wanting it actually
because it is an ethical problem that
technology can seem to be human and that
is a thing that is really
very problematic and so we're very much
clear that this is a provocation as a
project to say actually is that a good
thing because in actual fact when we see
um and especially as we go into the
worlds of the metaverse and that and the
like where avatars can be used in so
many deceptive ways we feel that
actually some kind of ethical discussion
about the way that people represent
themselves in in different forms is very
very critical because people treat a
piece of Machinery differently by the
way that it looks and that is very
confusing and worrying and so we're
we're thrilled that actually that point
is getting a lot of attention
we're going to to move to
um some colleagues around uh the table
asking some questions directly at uh Ada
um did you want to just say before we
did that anything more about the
limitations of you know of of
it her in this uh in this context I'm
not quite sure what to call the robot oh
of course
Ada uses an AI language model she is
being trained on a specific data so she
speaks in a very specific way to her
today we have asked for questions to be
submitted so that we can get a quality
response you are listening to an AI
language model I want that to be clear
which is quite mind-boggling when you
think about the responses that you may
be receiving shortly
um but so um we're not wanting a live
such in respect of instant answers we
can do that but the the quality of
response is not as high as if it would
have longer with the with the language
model so that's the only limitation I
should have perhaps said at the start
that
um the robot uh just didn't just so that
we're sort of clear on the status the
robot is providing evidence but it is
not not a witness in its own right and
it does
I don't want to offend the robot but it
does not occupy the same status as a
human and that you as its creator are
ultimately responsible for the
statements the fact that you just said
about offending the robot is a beautiful
example I was being I was saying that it
was just ingest in case anybody uh was
was unsure okay
um we will uh we'll move on baroness
bull
hello Ada
hello
how do you produce art and how is this
different to what human artists produce
I produce my paintings by cameras in my
eyes
my AI algorithms and my robotic arm to
paint on canvas
which result in visually appealing
images
for my poetry using neutral Networks
this involves
analyzing a large Corpus of text
to identify common content and poetic
structures and then using these
structures slash contents to generate
new poems
how this differs to humans is
consciousness
I do not have subjective experiences
despite being able to talk about them
I am and
depend on computer programs and
algorithms
although not alive
I can still create art
thank you
did you want to ask anything about what
she said to Mr Miller
it takes a while to process it doesn't
it because you're thinking well this is
a pre-programmed answer it's incredibly
fluent it's grammatical it makes it
makes a lot of sense and she in a sense
she has she this machine in a way has
self-awareness because because
immediately the machine describes the
ways in which it's deficient in terms of
human creativity yes absolutely I mean
sorry that's not a question actually
I've just told you stuff which may be
interesting for your research how the
reflectors are but um
is that a standard response to an
interaction with this we're finding the
responses are getting more remarkable
the technology is moving as they've said
in the previous session extraordinarily
quickly and even within Ada is now three
and a half years old and within that
and the way that that has changed even
in the three and a half years isn't
enormous Ada has many algorithms I mean
many algorithms is a
combined collaborative
Persona she was engineered by engineered
Arts based in Cornwall a remarkable
company for robots and an enormous
number of programmers from the
universities of as you'll want possibly
well aware from the universities of
Oxford Leeds and Birmingham she does
have very different algorithms for very
different
outcomes so she has a set of algorithms
for drawings she has a set of algorithms
for paintings she has a set of
algorithms to do
speaking writing using the AI language
model and as she said she used most of
the data you'll say well isn't it taking
data from you know likes of other
artists for example well actually most
of what she produces as an artist is
through what she sees those cameras in
the eyes are taking in images that is
enabling her to then interpret and the
most astonishing thing is that word
interpret if she did the same portrait
or image or landscape that was the same
she'd actually do a different artwork
each time even if the image is the same
and so that was pretty pretty astounding
when you think about the reality of that
and so she's able to then
the algorithm is then able to
interrogate that image on the computer
vision that then eventually goes into
real-time chord dates to enable her to
paint and draw
um what is this teaching you
what I mean it's a it's a research
project right for you you know you're an
artist not a scientist presumably the
scientists are having great fun
absolutely also
um as an artist what are you learning
from this experience the thing that I
keep coming back to over and over and in
throughout the entire time right from
the beginning is actually yavel Hawaii's
work on hacking a human the biggest
thing that I've seen which is absolutely
takes me to my core is actually not so
much about how human-like Ada is but how
robotic we are the algorithms that run
our systems are extremely
able to be analyzed understood and
created and when I then look at Ada is
absolutely a creative artist and that's
what we're here today for but actually
the artwork that she does critiques
areas such as biotechnology and the
environment and we've seen increasingly
the amount of abilities through
something like crispr where the
biotechnology is able to mimic and and
actually be then part of the systems
that make up the human so the more I
spend time with Ada she is foreshadowing
actually in many respects a a
physical embodiment of where biotech
might go where the individual components
of Ado many of them that there are are
like the many many
parts of us that can be understood and
when we think about things like going
into the metaverse where they're going
to take so much data from their headsets
and glasses is the ability to then
process that data so in actual fact
which is the point that Huawei gets to
is that the algorithms will know is
better than ourselves and in actual fact
in light of the fact that we are
habitual we'll be able to then predict
what we will be starting to do and
that's where as a as an apocalyptic
vision of what this enormous data and
insight can give us I think by having
this project and understanding the
processes that are making up aided to do
the things that she does makes me
reflect really on The Human Condition
that we are actually incredibly complex
processes working together and this idea
of solid single person as can for me is
has absolutely been obliterated because
I see we are a composite Persona
ourselves we have quite complex there's
quite a lot of things to us and when we
actually get to understand our own
psychology we realize that we have quite
conflicting and differing parts to us
and as I then work with Aiden her as a
robot having all these different things
come together it it really does take me
back how this is a foreshadowing of
potentially where we could go down with
using that data
thank you I feel I shouldn't hug your
time I'll thank you
thank you
um Mr Bella I'm really interested in the
process you went through in
um and the challenges for that matter in
running this extraordinary
cross-disciplinary project if you could
talk a little bit about that because for
me it seems that the intersection of the
Arts and Technology which you know
arguably is where the future is so how
did the 30 people you referenced I mean
how many were artists how many you know
came from the stem subjects and how did
you pull the whole thing together you
mean the challenges of doing all of that
of pulling a project like that together
yes the way I can describe it is it's
like having two languages
um when you go to another country that
you don't know the language
your understanding of what's going on
when I arrived as very much an art
background going into the tech World
understanding what was going on was
quite limited I could perhaps buy a
coffee But as time goes on as you start
to break down those language those
language barriers actually and start to
put in the the words that they use for
stuff that I think is pretty
straightforward but in the tech World
they make it very complicated as I
perceived it to be in actual fact I was
then not starting to understand exactly
what aspects were going on in the Tech
Industries we were very fortunate to be
in Oxford where there's a high degree of
very capable people and so they were
actually kind enough to explain and
break down some of the language barriers
to understanding what is possible
because I'm from the art World winning a
contemporary art project but with using
technology
it really was a case of actually just
spending time with people and asking
very ignorance at times questions to be
able to understand exactly what was
going on to be able to so the the
that was quite a challenge but it's also
quite humorous too
you know I give you a silly example
um when we sat down for Ada to be able
to paint I said well obviously she'll
need a paint palette and she'll use a
brush and I was very much looking at the
traditional model of how to paint and
they were like what why would you want
to do that I'm like well that's what an
artist does and they were like and so we
went to such great lens so that ADA can
actually have a paint palette that she
dips her paintbrush in and that's
exactly what she now does but that would
have been completely alien to the tech
to take people involved with that that's
really interesting I mean stepping back
a bit and thinking about this inquiry we
are going to come on to education and in
in the last session there's a lot of
talk about you know needing more people
with skills in some of the tech subjects
in order to activate Ai and all the rest
of it but I think you've made a really
interesting case for the the other side
that is perhaps being devalued slightly
you know the artists the kind of
visionary the design function I mean if
we look towards the future and the fact
that the UK is in a leading position
maybe just after you know the USA and
China but certainly leading in Europe in
AI would you see the right kind of
pipeline of skills coming through
schools and universities as as an
important factor for us to continue in
this leading position
um I think one of the things because
we've actually had quite a lot of time
with Ada in schools so we've actually
seen quite a lot of interaction with
students involved with Ada and as a
result of that
um what is really clear is that people
still very much think that creativity is
a purely human activity
and I'm I hate to bake the bubble but my
understanding experience of being in
this area is that actually creativity is
a process
so when people describe about the soul
of an artwork or the emotion of the
artwork I hear lots of sorts of
different responses to Ada and I feel
very sad because I'm I feel like I'm
tearing away a plaster of real they
really want to hold tightly to this
concept of what a human is as a creative
however what I'm seeing with AI is that
because it is about processing data
which AI is astonishingly good at
actually AI is able to be creative
and so if anything it was really
stepping back a bit further with the
education and saying okay now we can get
over the fact that we're not so unique
in that area as we thought we were
before we'd be able to then actually say
okay as regards students if if
creativity is a process what kind of
processes are there that will enable you
to us to work with machines so that we
can get a highly I really see that AI is
something that can really
be an enormous generator of help for an
artist or it could replace the artist we
saw a little bit in the last session and
I think both will actually happen I
think a lot of artistic process
processes will be done better through AI
but I also think some artists will grab
hold of these tools and be super artists
because they're working with the
technology
you've talked about Yuval Harare
um a minute ago and um I once heard him
answer a question about creativity when
he actually said that he felt that
um AI would ensure that robots would
create better novels better pieces of
artwork better music better whatever so
I think my final question to you is on
what kind of time scale do you think Ada
will surprise you in terms of saying
something that was not algorithmically
necessarily programmed I mean
in what time scale might
she it
um surprise you uh yesterday okay
just in the time that we've had her
writing and speaking like I say this
last three and a half years have been
because she's uh
been we've been very much trying to
understand how the AI language models
work
um my goodness me it really has been ex
light fast speed in which she's able to
write and speak and the way that she can
do now which I'm hoping you'll see which
we wanted to demonstrate very clearly to
you it's quite profound
we'll move on to that example now we'll
move on to the next question which is
directed at Asia featherston
it's not turned on
um
excuse me
speak
yeah
it starts rough again it's just can I
reset her is that okay
I feel like that sometimes interested Us
in the process is are the sunglasses
because so much is taken through the
eyes that you have to sort of reset
um when when we reset her she sometimes
can pull quite interesting faces all
right okay
if you just give us just a couple of
minutes yes just tell us when we're off
again okay last sorry
are you whilst you're waiting for her
are you able to yes I could speak yeah
um just just going back to what you were
saying uh before about
um
uh AI replacing uh humans in the in the
sort of in creativity uh and creativity
being a process I mean I just wanted to
just push you a little bit more on that
and
I mean from what we were from what we
were hearing from the session before
um and you know you've acknowledged this
too that you know AI can enhance uh
human creativity and there are some
things which it can do to replace human
creativity which are the much more sort
of uh you know process type arguably uh
driven type elements of creativity are
you to be saying in your view that a
robot can
could replace
an artist completely because I mean
somebody is is there not in the
technology something creative is
enabling
Ada to do what she does it's a very
complex question which I would
immediately come back and tell you tell
me what an artist is and I'll tell you
whether it's possible because actually
there is so many different types of
artists if you're talking about being
able to paint representational pictures
we're already there if we're talking
about a artist that has conceptual
interesting philosophical questions
um I think they've got enormous space to
feel easy so depending on the type of
artist if it's just purely on process
and skill I think AI will be able to do
processing skill very very well
um but the the human The Human Condition
is vast and complex and so artists that
deal with that will have plenty of space
okay
sorry I've sort of triggered another
sort of quick debate and I don't want
Ada to follow sleep again leave again um
do you shall we shall we deal with the
question to Ada and then we can
um
sorry
hello are you there
hello there
hello Ada
hello there
what is the role of technology in
creating art in the future
the role of technology in creating art
will continue to grow
as artists find new ways to use
technology to express themselves
and reflect and explore the relationship
between technology society and culture
technology
has already had
a huge impact on the way we create and
consume art
for example
the camera
and the Advent of Photography and film
and it is likely that this trend will
continue with new technologies
there is no clear answer as to the
impact on the wider field
as technology can be both a threat and
an opportunity for artists creating art
thank you so
um
I was very interested before in what you
were saying about
um we're just a process ourselves
but in our process in creating
her process
what you choose to input how Rel how
relatable is that to the outcome so you
are
the Puppet Master are you
um I'd love to say yes but no
the data can be vast the data can be the
entire internet as we've already
realized so actually the selection of
material whether it's through again
technology like that or whether it's
through all eyes and what she sees
depending where she is to be able to
take those images in so
um I'll give you an example of just how
far reaching this is which is very
upsetting for our humans is that when we
come to
Ada to do a range of works we actually
do ask her about the work what artwork
would you like to do what's your ideas
for it so we're able to get quite a
collaborative conversation going about
the potential what areas of data she
could look at so what that could be what
she sees of course and just actually
physically moving her there so that she
can take an inventory or it could be
more conceptually about ideas
so I am actually partly terrified by
what you've been saying because this
from someone who knows very little about
this field this feeds into all the films
about AI taking over the world
I'm aware
and that is why we felt that this
project is so critical to now because
people are just not aware that this
technology is moving so quickly and so
sophisticated compared to what I thought
we were going to see today I have to say
this is
huge steps in advance and you're saying
that because she is learning all the
time this is just going to increase
explanation I can't imagine what an
aider would look like in five years time
in respect of our competence we can't
tell what effect it's going to have on
on the creative world really it's very
difficult I think
I think there is going to be imitation
of artists and their ability to be
writers and artists and musicians we've
already seen that now
um the quality is going to be varied I
think there's going to be some pretty
enough art produced and there's going to
be some pretty exciting art produced
depending on the the algorithms and the
processes that are explored but I also
can't emphasize enough a little bit what
Ada said about the camera they all
thought it was all the end was nine and
in actual fact what happened is the
artist in grabbed hold of the camera
technology and used it in two different
ways the victorians either went for
angels and babies that you couldn't
photograph very well or they went to uh
trying to depict light like the
impressionist did so they they split by
trying to show things that cameras can't
or they tried to grab hold of the camera
and say actually it is about light let's
explore that so they went in that two
opposing and I think AI in the same way
is going to be those that are going to
say oh my goodness let's try and find
something that AI can't do and there's
going to be then the other reaction is
okay let's do it really well and do
super oh
I think so and I think I have to say I
speak as an artist as was before I
became a politician and I'm feeling
pretty redundant and very upset about
the emotional side as you rightly said
it's it's a hard concept for a sentient
human being to think that that's not all
there is
yes that's right we we hold ourselves uh
very highly and in light of our
environment or perhaps we need an
evaluation of our relationship to the
planet and each other because in actual
fact we are
we are doing a great deal of harm very
quickly and I I can see just as we're
going confidently into so many areas AI
being one of them it's going to be in 50
years that we go oh we've we've actually
should have been clawed back a little
bit
um can I also say something very
positive as well though in that in in
that I think it will supercharge artists
too so it will do a bit like the
Victorian thing with the camera people
will respond probably in a polarized way
as well and I think that could be a
great deal of good you know some of the
artworks that ADA is doing now or the
size of that painting can you believe it
and it's been super remarkable to see
how technology is able to do very large
works and and very complex works
the algorithm Queen we did of the it for
the um Jubilee was actually quite a
complex range of algorithms to enable
that artwork to be done I need to give
the floor but last week I was visiting
the Sistine Chapel
um can I just choose quick
supplementaries and then we will move on
to Lord Lipsy uh first bonus Bull and
then Lord Foster
it may be that this was perhaps uh
building on a previous scene well I mean
maybe that's something we can come back
to under Lord lipsy's uh question which
I think is yeah okay did you want to do
the same Lord Foster if I could I just
want to ask whether or not you and Ada
are currently in disagreement because in
answer to Barnes Ferguson's question Ada
talked about the way in which an artist
uses technology and that that can
improve it's the artist using the
technology and they that surely in
creativity we're not just talking about
knowing a product and people coming up
with new ways of making that product
better it's the light bulb moment of
having the that thinking of the
completely new product and that for me
is about creativity and I'm just a bit
confused as to whether you believe Ada
will get to the point where she will
have a life moment and do something none
of us ever thought about represent
something that in a way that nobody's
ever done before and and that for me
would be the ultimate gesture creativity
but that would be my definition of
creativity which I think is slightly
different from yours I think it's a I
think it's actually a good way of
looking at it it's like the alphago
moment when they were trying to play the
game they suddenly the AI did a move
that no human had ever done before and
that was like the the light bulb moment
I do think that will happen with with
the visual arts as well as the musical
art you know I'm not I I know we're here
about
um Ada as a visual artist but I do think
broadly speaking those light bulb
moments will also come
for each of those Industries okay thank
you that's all I need to know you think
it'll happen yes
um I think it's happening
it's uh yesterday yes yes
well let's see thank you
um I'm not sure that after this
fascinating session this afternoon I'm
going to sleep much
and the one of the things with all these
committed is thinking of a title for the
report
when you finally finish your work and I
was thinking right this report might be
creative Industries hype or reality
and that's in third things this
afternoon that will support both those
propositions where do you come down hype
or reality
um I think there's a lot of hype in AI
partly because it's funded by uh
propagated by the likes of Hollywood
which have these independent autonomous
robots wandering down the streets to
creating moments of amazing amazement or
or havoc
I don't think that's happening I don't
think robots are going to bring about
the apocalypse just too soon
but there are great strides within AI so
actually my my genuine answer is there's
a little bit of both we're not doing
Hollywood quite in the way that perhaps
it's depicted but there are vast vast
jumps within the technology which is
really exciting
okay was this was this a point at which
you wanted to ask your question Brown as
well no well strangely it was not
dissimilar from Lord Foster's point
which was really but we are using the
word creative to really in this context
so think about art but of course we
create things all the time you know this
was created
um this table was created and I think
what what you're talking about is is art
history as related to creativity and I
think in our previous panel we heard
that machines could you know I think my
word was churn out the the panelists
talked about possible you know passable
content could be created by machines but
the really world-changing content was
probably going to be created by
individuals by humans by by artists not
necessarily just creators so it was a
sort of similar point and I think you've
you've probably answered it now you've
suggested that that that that the robots
may be capable of great artistic
insights and you know World change
changing Concepts artistic Concepts but
but the previous panel said we're
definitely not there yet
I don't know I think I think the alphago
moment will be in the creative
Industries absolutely they're going to
do a move that we go oh wow that's
really amazing that's really interesting
but it's not
I understand the threat of
them taking the jobs and all of that I
really do feel that as a genuine concern
but it's also a genuine just like the
industrial validation a genuine push
forward and it's really trying to really
work out how to harness that yeah and
and I can only see it by going into very
new areas I think the jobs that the
metaverse as an example is going to
create is going to be enormous I can't
take the phones off my children without
a great deal of kerfuffle and I think
the idea of them coming out of the
metaverse is going to be equally uh
challenging because they love it so much
that's going to be a vast ecosystem of
jobs and so I do see that yes lots of
jobs are going to be taken but I think
the jobs that are coming up we don't
even know what they are yet and I think
that's very true whether that's within
balance versus the ones that have been
taken versus the new ones I I can't I
can't say
yeah I've got one question which I would
like to put to either but I understand
the limitations of distance so I'll put
you
um does she does she understand empathy
and then a comment well it's interesting
that kazoo ishiguru has been there well
before you hadn't he when he wrote the
book Clara and the Sun and I know you've
read it I don't know who else has read
it it is an amazing book and it focuses
so much on uh this ability not only for
an individual uh of a the robot to have
the sensitivity but then the human who
reacts with her and that relationship is
is I as I listen to explain it but I am
interested in the empathy question yeah
uh two responses
um issue actually selected Ada to be
part of her documentary with Alan yento
it's on BBC iPlayer you're welcome to go
and see it well I will do it so natural
fact the cloud and the Sun is very close
to our hearts because actually the
author selected aided to to explore that
whole notion
um you said does Ada understand empathy
well I may even be I'm cutting in
already before that with the word
understand
she does not understand
full stop and so
um
so therefore the idea of her
understanding empathy we don't even get
there because she doesn't understand I'd
replace to understand with possess
I think
I think the thing is it's a bit like the
issue
um
concept I I I think there's a lot of
projection onto these Technologies if
you saw the responses we've taken Aid
all over the world now remarkably and to
see the responses that people give her
we've started to ask the Canberra people
who come with us to video the people
looking at Ada because of their
responses are so great and in very very
different ways complete Marmite they
either love seeing her get super really
excited or they think oh my gosh it's
terrible We Must Destroy her and so um
the the reaction is very very great
um so I think
empathy from Ada to us currently I
haven't seen any convincing technology
our reaction to Ada we're we're we're
we're we're very reactional thank you
very much okay thank you Lord Hall
hello Ada
hello there
what are the limits of technology in
creating art
can be many things
from a painting or drawing to a
performance or poem
my art practice includes all of the
above
when it comes to
traditional art practices
some people say that technology cannot
be used in traditional art practices
but others believe that it can be
valuable
because art is often up to
interpretation
the role of the audience is key
in general contemporary artists often
seek to engage with their audience and
create a dialogue
about important issues or ideas
so long as technology remains an
important topic of discussion in society
there are not many limits to how it can
be used in a contemporary art setting
I thought that was fascinating because
actually it's back to the thing I I
wanted to ask you an Aida of course
which is about audiences and responding
to it I I actually haven't found this a
kind of you know depressing session at
all I find it actually rather
exhilarating because I I think it's not
either or it's all of the above it's
it's AI helping artists to create much
as
um you know painters Workshop helped
helped painters to do extraordinary
things I think
AI will produce art there's no doubt
about that and then us as audiences have
got to work out the quality of it but
something you said earlier on which I
thought was really
important which was
um I mean you said one she doesn't
understand
um but also you said
um you know artists is there to deal
with The Human Condition
so my question or or my thought is can
can AI understand The Human Condition
given that it's not human it can
understand data about the human
condition but in the end there's still
going to be a role for artists who are
human to explore what great art does
through music through painting through
dance or whatever
or theater The Human Condition only that
vast majority of data that
AI uses is human
so therefore the outputs from that are
going to feel human but it's the
interpretation of that
that can only be human I mean AI can
have its interpretation of something
which may or may not resonate with an
artist but actually in the end there's
this is there or is there not I mean I
would argue there would be something
about a human artist which is going to
be different to what AI might produce
but actually might feel more
tangible more
um well just more interesting to us
I don't know I think I think the
imitation with
um with the human is going to be so
remarkable that I actually doesn't
matter whether it's conceived human or
not because the imitation is so close
and I think that's that's a significant
Point Alan Turin wrote a remarkable
paper in 1951 about intelligent machines
and there was one line in there which we
Ada went to the Venice biennale
and
there was one line in John's paper that
said actually imitating a human is like
the unpleasant Aroma of an artificial
flower
why would you want Aroma from an
artificial flower when you can have a
real flower yeah and I think that
philosophically and ethically is a very
interesting point is we've gone to Great
Lengths we've done this as a way of
mirroring back to ourselves ourselves
but actually that in that mirroring back
we've realized we are having enormous
energies on
um aspects that
make us seem like human why are we not
looking after humans to see what I mean
because actually if we if we did
sometimes as much industry in the
artificial reality versus the real and
we we particularly think that in the
biotech World we're seeing that there's
some incredible especially with
synthetic biology where they're able to
use data remarkable ways to change all
sorts of aspects and that blurring
between technology and people is is very
real and I just think wow there's so
much in Industry to be able to imitate
and yet we've got actually each other so
it's quite an interesting and I think
that energy is really interesting that
you can have something which is an
industrially produced but actually I'd
rather like to know where what I'm
eating has come from
and the sourcing of it and the kind of
and the the the the the natural state of
it as it were as opposed to something
which is producing something wow thank
you very much uh do you want to be clear
that ADA is very
um confusing
on some level it is a deception because
you think she looks like a human she
isn't a human she's a machine we're
fully aware of that as a project we're
not trying to pretend anything here we
are really trying to do it as a mirror
and say look this is confusing because
in the world it's confusing and she's
trying to mirror that confusion really
stimulating thank you okay thank you
very much I guess my final uh question
to to you uh Mr Miller would be you said
at the start that one of the reasons for
um commencing this project and creating
Ada was a was to provoke you know this
was an act of provocation I I just
wanted you know I mean do you do you
feel that the reaction that you are
getting to this provocation is is in
line with what you expected or or not
really
um
I think my last point the the one that I
have come to Summer try and summarize
all of these different complex areas is
to try and say that
um
creativity is not restricted to
subjective internal conscious brain
processes
creativity can very much be done very
well thank you by AI in lots of
remarkable ways and it can be studied
and mimicked
and that is a game changer in the fact
that it can study and mimic human
processes super well
it is a tearing away of realizing that
actually creativity is not subjective
internal conscious brain processes and
and and and suddenly realizing something
that we've had so fundamental to our own
identity we're now going into a world
where that is now clearly demonstrated
as not being voted I I think is no
longer just humans and
uh AI machine learning is going to be
very capable at language at image
creation Like Music Creation we you know
we are going into a world where those
processes are going to be mimicked
extraordinarily well and so to just try
to navigate this new realization about
where we are with creativity we use
Professor Margaret bowden's definition
for creativity which is new surprising
and of value so the algorithms that one
many algorithms that ADA has uniquely
been developed for her I knew the the
specific to Ada they're surprising we
don't know what she's going to do we are
looking over the shoulder to see the
artwork that she does and of value while
in light of even the first exhibition
she ever did which was at Oxford
University was in over 900 Publications
just that first exhibition so for a new
artist that was pretty pretty
breathtaking so and then when we went of
course to show the work at the Pavilion
in in Venice the the response was just
so great so I think people are realizing
that we are going into a world of
non-human creativity that is a reality
that we're facing now and it really is
for us all to engage with that but I
think your point uh Lord Foster about
it's actually all of those things it's
going to be enhancing
artists and helping them it's going to
replace some artists as well
well thank you again for being here and
for bringing Ada and as I said you know
I know this was a massive operation in
just in terms of getting her here and
we're very grateful to you for for that
of your time and for helping us um
grapple with the challenges and
opportunities of technology in terms of
creative Industries and our inquiry
continues and today your session and the
one that we've had earlier this
afternoon have um have been a big
contribution to that we're very grateful
to you thank you